Push zoom lens (Dolly Zoom)
Is the most often confusing
And one of the exaggerated shooting techniques
In a few popular movies in the history of film
There have been some tips
It is famous for its peculiar visual effects.
But the shooting method of this lens
Also teach us a lot of ideas about filmmaking.
It shows different types of lenses and how to use them
It strengthens the emotions in the scene
And it is also used in some subtleties that you might not notice.
Let us take a look
The zoom zoom lens is sometimes treated as
An effect that can express the vertical direction
This lens first appeared in Hitchcock's 1958 movie "Ecstasy"
You need a smooth track and a steady zoom to get it done
Therefore, the use of this lens has not developed rapidly.
This is actually a kind of zooming in or out through the lens zoom.
And the track is pushed closer or farther away
Optical illusion
The result will result in a change in the foreground position
But the background is squeezed or stretched depending on the direction in which the camera moves.
This lens actually teaches us an important principle about filming.
If you want to see the difference between the wide-angle lens and the telescope head
The simplest example is to observe the zoom zoom lens.
To compare how it starts and how to end it
The zoom zoom lens can be like a telescope head
Start from where the camera is far enough and the focal length is large enough
Because the lens is shot in a small part
Resulting in a smaller field of view that the background can accommodate
But when you change the focus by zooming in and zooming in on the camera
You will find that the foreground has not changed but the background can accommodate a wider range of views.
The result will be the same as the subject
But expanded the scope of the background to accommodate other things
So when you change from the telescope head to the wide-angle lens
Can accommodate a wider space through the changed focal length
You usually use a telescope head to take close-ups.
In order to keep the audience focused on the prospects
When you shoot with a telescope head
Because less background can be captured
Will cause the background to change quickly after the foreground
This lens has taken a lot of cool perspectives.
People will look good under the telescope
Because their faces are not deformed by wide-angle lenses.
Wide-angle lenses are more often used in shooting backgrounds
So it's more suitable for outdoor shooting when you want to capture the scenery.
So using either lens is a trade-off
Push track scene can be used as a lens
Transition screen to another lens
And this also has a different emotional response to the audience.
The zoom zoom lens in "Ecstasy" brings a sense of height
This increase in height sense
Perfectly shows how the telescope head shows a narrower perspective in the background
So the background image we shot is more or less
The result is an optical illusion that makes people feel dizzy
This lens will be disturbing
Even let some people feel like vomiting
Because this is a sensory experience that is impossible to perceive through physical means.
Unless it is using some different types of lens transformations
The dining scene of "The Good Guys" is the most confusing part
Quickly transform through the landscape around them in an impossible way
Because Henry’s world is breaking down
And his stubborn temper exacerbates this impossible lens movement.
He was deeply puzzled by the results of this meal.
This zoom makes us really close to Henry
Just as he was caught is inevitable
As I said before, the wide-angle lens will make people look a bit strange.
The most famous zoom zoom lens in Jaws
Is to quickly switch to wide-angle lens
Make his face look a bit elongated and unnatural
And let the rest of the store look strange
Three examples of "Ecstasy", "Great White Shark" and "Four Seas Good Guys"
They are all typical examples when it comes to pushing zoom lenses.
But the problem is when teaching this shot
But because people feel like they are trying to be classics
Make the display of this lens only in the example
But in fact, it is more often able to show your talents.
This is the visual effect of the sensory experience.
Often used in the state of mind after revealing supernatural phenomena or taking drugs
I especially enjoy the effect of using the zoom zoom lens in The Lord of the Rings.
Because of the caves that are gradually expanding in the woods
It looks like the door to the fourth wall is being opened to meet the enemy.
This lens is also often used in the climax of making movies.
In the unlikely event that your hero fails, you can add a little bit of beauty.
This lens is also useful in animations.
Brad Bod used this technique extensively in his films.
The food critic’s memory is to enhance the effect with a zoom zoom lens.
Thus simulating the process of transferring from one world to another
Especially in computer animation
There is often an exclusive opportunity to make some interesting attempts on photos.
Because the computer animation completely controls the position of the target
Like the relationship between the mouse Remy and the chef Gust.
The zoom zoom lens is no longer a lost viewer
Instead, explain their germinated emotional relationship
As close to each other as you can see
There is also a similar zoom zoom lens in Superman Special Forces.
Just as the lady is closer to her ambition
These two examples did not cause damage to the picture.
But it also attracted us to notice the sign squeeze effect of this lens.
For film creators
The zoom zoom lens is indeed a novel shooting lens
But remember that this is more important than the rough shooting trick.
Hitchcock uses this lens to express depth
Martin Scorsese uses this lens to express stubbornness
Bradbold uses this lens to express visual clues
So always pay attention to the zoom zoom lens
thanks for watching